vous allez dans un hôpital pour vous
faire soigner les yeux ou pour soigner
un ongle incarné vous risquez d'attraper
le coc vida dans certains cas d'une
façon qui peut être extrêmement grave
c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez
est ahurissant
non pas qu'on attrape des maladies
nosocomiales mais qu'on attrape une
maladie nosocomiale qui est parfaitement
évitables par la vaccination
donc on demande simplement ces personnes
d'exercer leur liberté personnelle mais
deux ne veut pas nuire puisque le prg un
premier principe médicale puisqu'on en
est à la question des soignants c'est ne
pas nuire c'est le premier grand
principe
or si ces personnes qui sont chargées de
soins transmettent une maladie qui dans
certains cas est plus grave que celle
pour laquelle on vient se soigner c'est
le monde à l'envers et je comprends très
bien alors j'ai vu les chiffres il
semble qu'aujourd'hui il environ les
trois quarts de la population française
soit en faveur des cette obligation
bien entendu bien entendu
qui dit obligation cela suppose quelque
forme de contrainte voire de menaces de
sanctions et donc et donc de sanction
je suppose qu'il peut y avoir un certain
de sanction graduée mais je ne je suis
persuadé que le simple fait de
l'obligation encouragerait un grand
nombre de ceux qui sont aujourd'hui
réticents à se faire vacciner même sans
la crainte d'une sanction le caractère
simplement obligatoire à lui même des
effets si je puis dire obligeant pour un
esprit si libre soit il
[Musique]